you cannot have a game convention this
year and not talk about Batman Arkham
City I'm telling you this game out of
this world I mean the big shock for me
was that the first thing you do is you
play as Catwoman which I didn't expect
to do but you play as Catwoman in this
game and hathaways got a big job ahead
of her if she's gonna top this I'm not
gonna lie
a game Catwoman hottest that woman ever
good luck Anne Hathaway you're gonna
need it then you got to take on two-face
they did a great job with two babes they
actually did the Gollum smegal thing
with them which is you know the dual
personality he kind of argues with
himself leeway to get by in this respect
I thought that was awesome the only
bummer is that kicked me off of this
game like a few minutes in so I didn't
get to get as far as I could've but I
saw someone throwing down with Harley
Quinn I saw the Riddler this game is
everything that was missing from the
first one was missing for a point and
purpose and I liked that because they
could have it in this game now and the
battle systems just how you remember it
I mean you're complete badass you wreck
like 28 guys and you're like I didn't
get it I think it's scathed that's
awesome some of the things that he does
when you counter it's a little different
but the act of pulling it off Sammis has
always been and again if it ain't broke
don't fix it Thank You Walker brothers
for not fixing Batman
alright Mass Effect 3 and I'm gonna
level with you guys there might be a
couple of things that you consider
spoilers but if something they unveiled
at an expo like this months before the
game comes out so I don't think it's a
big spoiler but it's one mission so in
Mass Effect 3 I was with Liara
Garrus and we're doing a mission for Rex
and Morton solace was there so you know
those guys are in the game we're going
after a female Croghan which is pretty
sweet because there's something about
her that can cure the genophage in the
grand scheme of things it doesn't really
matter but a Rex needs a date and I'm
there for him the segment that I play
you're actually going up against
Cerberus Cerberus it's been
indoctrinated by the Reapers
so hey allies today enemies tomorrow
there were douchebags in the first game
anyway so it doesn't matter but the
battle systems just as you remember so
if you've played Mass Effect again
you're going to jump right into this
game which I like that they're going on
with the ammo system that Mass Effect 2
has if it ain't broke don't fix it I
mean with Mass Effect 2 as opposed to
Mass Effect 1 I felt like they fix what
they needed to fix and it seems that
between Mass Effect 2 and Mass Effect 3
there's not much defects or the like
dude we're just gonna roll with it the
graphics were a lot sharper but the game
Solid the galaxy is coming to an end is
up to you to stop it I'm just telling
you a Mass Effect 3 is probably the
single most anticipated game for me
that's coming out
but no matter what scars you bear
whatever uniform you wear
you can find a clue
never
Commander Shepard